Oh.
This one is yours, too.
You sound surprised.
I suppose I am.
It's not at all like the
others you donated, is it?
It is not.
The others are…
Well, they were
to my father's tastes.
If Lady Danbury is to be
believed,
this one was
a favourite of my mother's.
I have never understood why.
It is very beautiful.
It reminds me of
waking up in the country.
First thing in the morning.
When I'm all alone.
And I've not yet spoken to
a soul.
I look outside the window
and it is…
serene.
It's as if I could be
the only person left
in the world and yet
somehow I am not lonely.
I am comforted.
At peace.
The others are certainly
very grand
and impressive but,
this one…
This one is intimate.
It's been a pleasure
working with you, comrade.
Pleasure's mine.
Wait, wait! Wait!
Really?
That's it?
You're just gonna walk away
like this never happened?
Well that's what
professionals do, right?
Sarah, I've just had
the best day of my life.
John B, you're gonna blow
our cover.
Look, I don't care about
my cover, Sarah.
I don't care
if my friends find out
or your boyfriend
with his frosted tips.
Look, yesterday I didn't
even know who you were.
And, today, I'm like…
Sarah Cameron.
And, honestly, in my limited
experience, that's rare.
That's, like, eclipse rare.
Like a blind person
seeing colour
for the first time rare
or, like, Bigfoot evidence
or the Northern Lights.
Look, I can't pretend like
this isn't real,
like this didn't happen.
-I'm sorry. I--
-Shut up.
I can't pretend, either.
Hey, man, get a room.
What are you gonna tell
Jackson?
-Diarrhoea attack.
-God.
He's never gonna speak to me
again, is he?
Why didn't you say goodbye?
I was letting him
off the hook.
They're not gonna want
their golden boy
dating someone
like me anyway so,
why go through
the fate stuff?
Yeah, well.
If you don't open
yourself up,
you're never gonna find out.
No.
-No therapy, remember.
-What? Oh. Sorry.
You all right?
I've got a jumper.
So chivalrous.
Well, actually,
there's some Nutella
on it, so not exactly.
Great.
Why are your arms
so freakishly long?
They're not.
Just roll up your sleeves,
you fool!
This one.
I'm a virgin!
-What?
-I…
I'm a virgin,
and I thought you should
know that I am.
Yeah, that's totally cool.
-No judgement.
-Cool.
Glad I shared.
I'm gonna head off now.
Oh. Ok.
-Yeah.
Strange time to practice.
But better late than never.
I swear I'm not a stalker.
I just really had to talk
to you.
How'd you find me?
Do you even have to ask?
Elsa tracks my phone.
First off,
it sucks you're avoiding me.
I put myself out there
and I was honest with you
and for that I get
the silent treatment?
Even if you don't feel
the same,
you could at least be there
for me as a friend.
You're making me feel crazy!
Honestly,
if I knew
that you were gonna be
all weird
and that this was gonna
jeopardise our friendship,
I never in a million years
would have told you
how I felt.
Because it is becoming
incredibly clear that
you don't feel the same way.
Aleksander--
I have been fighting
this war
alone for so long.
I've buried so many
good soldiers,
friends.
The coffers are running dry.
The noose tightens.
And our own people
are turning against Grisha,
just as their kin once did.
You are not alone.
I've been waiting
a long time for you.
I should go.
You lied to me
from the very beginning.
You used me as a way to keep
your brother alive.
I didn't lie to you.
I just… I couldn't tell you
everything right away.
Mildred!
You lied.
Until the lie
didn't serve you anymore.
Then you decided to
tell the truth.
And I understand that
the world has not been kind
to you
and I am sorry for that,
I truly am.
But that doesn't give you
the right
to dissemble at
every possible opportunity
to the people around you
whose only mistake was
to care about you.
I know that.
Do you?
Because I honestly
don't think that you do.
My feelings for you
are real.
I don't think
that you have any idea
what your feelings are.
Because you have been lying
for so long.
It's second nature to you.
You even lie to yourself.
Well, your lying
and your selfishness
have cost me everything.
I don't know
what my life is anymore.
I don't understand
how I got so
tangled up in you.
And I don't understand
whether my feelings for you
are real
and you waltzed into
my heart
and I cannot get you out.
Gwendolyn.
I love you.
I don't even know what
I'm supposed to say to that.
And, anyway,
I don't believe you!
What I kept from you,
that was not easy
for me to do.
I wanted to tell you
everything.
And I understand how awful
that would make you feel.
How used you must have felt.
The lies I told to get into
that hospital,
to get closer to Edmund,
those were amoral acts and I
understand that completely,
but you must understand that
I had no choice.
And, if I had to, I would do
it all over again.
I wish you could leave the
pain I've caused behind us.
Let go of the resentment,
the suspicion.
My feelings for you are
the truest thing in me.
I love you. Do you hear me?
I love you.
What are you doing here?
So this is your room, huh?
Yes, and why are you in it?
Do you like him, Hunter?
Why are you here?
Do you like him?
Yeah, I do.
Ok, then.
That's that.
That's what?
I'm just Maxine's
dumb friend, remember?
Who climbs through a window?
This isn't some rapey
John Hughes mo--
What the hell was that?
Who kisses someone
right after
they use the word rapey
in a sentence?
Sorry, it's just I know you
were on that date tonight
and Maxine won't shut up
about how perfect
you and Hunter are
and I can't stop thinking
about you.
The other day
when you grabbed me--
Is he here now?
No.
Good.
Because, you know,
I'll sort him out for you
if I have to.
Oi.
Dead boyfriend!
Give it up, mate! It's over.
Who is he, Poppins?
How are you still standing?
I think I'm crazy.
I think you're surprisingly
sane, considering.
Look.
I know what it feels like.
You feel like
you can't find--
Are you sure?
Yes.
Ok.